[Music]
good evening forget everything you think
you know what
everyone is raving about Dungeons and
Dragons
it's the kind of Epic fun you've been
waiting for protect it with your very
life I will
all this
none of us can say our lives gone the
way we'd hoped I did think you'd serve
longer we got an early release
good behavior yeah baby good it charms
its way into your heart oh God I could
kiss you try it
the most Chris Pine a Chris Pine
performance has been in a long time just
because that sentence is symmetrical
doesn't make it not nonsense a crowd
pleaser that actually pleases it's a
gift for everyone
all right take me down this is absurdly
high it's not what we discussed
it's the best movie of the year
anything you want to add
I'm good
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
only in theaters March 31st
[Music]
thank you